well I think we'll go ahead and get
started I think there's more people
coming but we'll let them come in late
and get their pizza it's my pleasure to
introduce dr. Tiffany vino she's from
the University of Michigan where she
runs the community health informatics
lab and she's an assistant professor of
information and of health buffet about
health behavior and health education so
some stuff that's really interesting to
all of us I've had the privilege of
working with Tiffany on the biomedical
library and informatics review committee
the study section for the National
Library medicine and she's also received
awards from the canadian association of
information science the American Society
for information science and technology
association for library and information
science and many others she's going to
talk today about her work investigating
the access and use of health information
by people in communities especially
those as I understand it that experience
health disparities yes so let's hear
from dr. vino thank you very much Paul
for hosting me and for Lynn for all the
help with arrangements and I really
appreciate the opportunity to share my
research with all of you so today I'm
going to be talking about how community
matters for health informatics and yes
it's a context that looks at health
disparities so it's primarily
marginalized populations and if any of
you are interested in my publications or
finding out more about my work this is
my website so I'm going to talk about
how i came to doing this work an overall
flavor with regards to my research
program as well as some of the central
findings that I believe will hopefully
make a strong case for you that
community health informatics is an
important approach to take and then I
will look at some future future work so
I wanted to start with a sort of
personal story which is the kind of work
I was doing that brought me to this so
initially I was working in Canada i
received my master's degree in the early
90s in library information science I
know some of you have that background
here and I started working in the
nonprofit sector i worked in
health-related nonprofits for 10 years
and one of the organizations i began to
work with focused on HIV treatment
information in canada so it started
working in a national organization and
one of the things that's important to
know about this organization
is that it came out of a specific fact
related to health disparities which is
that in Canada and many other Western
countries the burden of HIV has really
been disproportionately affecting men
who have sex with men so gay and
bisexual men as well as people who don't
identify as such but our risk so this
particular fact led to quite a lot of
activism both through act up in the US
here as well in Canada we had AIDS
Action now which did a lot of treatment
activism and then got really involved in
providing treatment information for
people who are positive as a way to try
to stay alive and they started to
approach that focused on peer based
treatment information exchange and
ultimately this organization then became
a nonprofit that was very successful and
ultimately received national funding to
offer their services across Canada and
when I started working there there were
a number of services that were offered
there was telephone treatment
information counseling we had
consumer-oriented publications for
people with HIV we had books and
libraries and we also had a website
that's what it looked like in not in the
90s that looks a lot different now and
so I started working in this
organization as director of information
services so I was handling website
library and a number of other related
things that just the general technology
side of the organization but one of the
things that started to happen around the
time that I started working in 2000 was
that the demographics of the disease
started to change the disease started to
disproportionately affect in terms of
new infections Aboriginal populations
new immigrants injection drug users
there was a whole group of people that
were now being affected by the disease
and they were rather annoyed with Katie
which was the name of the organization
that i worked at when I started it was
in a lot of turmoil with trying to
figure out how are we going to serve
this new these new populations that are
have very different needs from the
people who started it as an organization
so this judge this question of how are
we going to adopt in order to meet our
new audiences became something that the
organization was really struggling with
and that's something that I really kind
of took
through my work and at that time I
really started to look at this general
problem of challenges of reach and
impact with regards to health
information services and technologies so
many of you probably know there's still
a proportion of people who don't use the
internet in the US still one in five
around twenty percent most health
informatics applications that are
focused on consumers have shown
differential adoption amongst African
Americans often that's over and above
internet access differentials we've also
seen the work in public health shows the
lot of work that health communication
programs typically are less effective
for people with low SES backgrounds so
typically there's quite there are groups
of people that are not being reached and
it actually goes back to the mid 20th
century there was a study in 1949 that
showed that libraries were being used
only by a small proportion of people and
typically is the same demographic
factors over and over that are affecting
things race disability geography SES and
SES meaning socioeconomic status so I
then I came to the US and I started to
look at these issues in a u.s. context
and here again we see there's
significant racial disparities with
regards to new HIV infections as well
people are dying faster with HIV as
these data show who are african-american
so we see more infections and people not
doing as well once they have it so this
particular problem of health disparities
clusters around demographic populations
but this diagram also illustrates that
it clusters around geography to this
diagram shows that in the Detroit area
which is one of the areas that I work in
red is a higher rate of diabetes higher
diabetes prevalence and as you can see
Detroit which has ninety two percent of
an african-american population has much
higher prevalence of diabetes than other
areas so this particular set of problems
is one that motivated my interest in
going back to do a PhD and ultimately my
research program
at you ms I so my research program
really focuses on this central question
of what health information technologies
and services would look like if the
needs and experiences of marginalized
groups were at the center of their
design and implementation and my goal
here really is you can sort of tell from
the story I told you is to try to
improve reach and impact of existing
services and aim to find new models so
i've been working in several sort of
research streams i'm going to primarily
speak about number one today which
relates to community oriented factors
that affect access to and use of health
information so just so i can ground us
what do i what I mean when I'm saying
community i'm using a sociological
definition going back to max viveiros
work in the 1920s he talks about the
idea of belonging as a sort of center of
the idea of community so i'm working
with a core idea of belonging and the
sociological work and work in
anthropology geography etc political
science also that there are multiple
ways that this belonging can be produced
it can be produced by geographic
proximity by institutions that create
things like regional boundaries can be
created by interactions can be created
by effective bonds sometimes more than
one thing at a time but there are
multiple ways that community may be
established and in my interests I'm
interested in multiple in this
multiplicity of community forms and just
to sort of point something out i'm
typically doing research at a meso level
of social organization and by that i
mean it's in between the micro level of
the individual and the macro level of
whole societies economies etc and the
metse level includes things like
community family network organisation as
a unit of analysis so the way that I
approach my research to try to address
this question is to look at a number of
different kinds
groups or communities and also to look
at a range of different health issues
and also to participate in
community-based research strategies so a
lot of my work is done in partnership
with nonprofit organizations public
health organizations health care
providers libraries a whole range of
stakeholders so if you take away one
thing from today the central point that
I'm hoping you will take away is that
this talk is a call to community health
informatics as an approach to research
to print to practice and what do I mean
by that i'm going to work through that
today and why is it important so i'm
going to talk about some findings across
multiple studies and i will talk about
the central sort of claims i'm making
here so across several studies i have
looked at this issue of communities
having different information
environments and and relatedly different
access to information related to health
and so i'm going to talk to you about a
positive example here which is in a high
prevalence community gaining more access
to information through involvement in
that community so first i'll talk about
the young men's study this was a project
that was done with young men who have
sex with men i'm going to just say MSM
as our definition and looking at HIV
this project began through an effort to
try to promote HIV testing in this group
so this was the question that we started
out with whether gay community
involvement and that's not necessarily
identity but it's how much you're
actually in touch with other gay people
how much you are in touch with
institutions going to events things like
that and we did a web survey as well as
qualitative research that was looking at
people who had high community
involvement in southeastern Michigan I
just give you an idea of how it was
measuring community involvement these
are some of the items things like how
many of your friends are also MSM things
like that and the survey demographics
typically me this was a young group the
average age was 20
and majority african-american which was
what we were hoping for because of the
demographics of the disease in the area
I'm in also given their age as you might
expect not many of them at completed
University at this point the majority
identified as gay so one thing to note
that's kind of important is that gay
community involvement actually wasn't
associated with any other demographic
factors that's what this regression
shows so it's an independent factor so
I'm going to walk you through a series
of linear regressions that we're done
the dependent variable is at the top
basically highlighting here the role of
gay community involvement as an
association or as a predictor of that
dependent variable so as we see here gay
community involvement was resuscitated
with lower perceived costs socially of
looking for information about HIV so
people felt like others wouldn't
necessarily judge them or make them feel
bad this variable is network expertise
accessibility this is about having
people in your social network that you
can talk to about the disease and that
you feel like are knowledgeable about it
people who are more involved in the gay
community had more network expertise
accessibility also people who were more
involved in the gay community felt that
the disease was more relevant to their
group this is a variable called
community relevance so and further
people were getting information without
looking for it that's the variable here
incidental information acquisition that
was happening more if they were more
involved with a gay community as well
also they looked for information about
the disease more often the more they
were involved so across all of these
factors the most consistent variable
that was predicting all of these factors
was community involvement also in
looking at people using HIV information
to make decisions regarding their health
again we found that a community related
variable was an important predictor
there as well as acquiring the
information and one thing that was
interesting was that nineteen percent of
the variance
overall in information use was predicted
by that relevance variable so i did a
structural equation model to look at
this this particular set of variables
and basically this means that the model
fit was good but this is showing here
that gay community involvement was
predicting information acquisition and
indirectly it was predicting information
use and that each of these variables
related to community involvement were
affecting people's acquisition of
information and their use of it and
overall twenty-eight percent of the
variance in information use was
explained by these variables so these
are somewhat impressive numbers but
there's still quite a lot that's
unexplained and so we also did a
qualitative analysis to try to figure
out what else might be going on with
regards to information interaction and
this in this particular work we did
grounded theory and these are based on
the interviews with young men who were
more involved with the gay community and
the theme that really arose here was
information sharing as an expression of
pro-social community values and so here
we see people talking about the
community involvement as being a really
important thing for them in terms of
pro-social action and for some people
there was even a sense that informing
other people was an important expression
of their community belonging so those
were the conditions and these were some
of the things that they were doing in
order to try to share information with
others things like referring people to
try to get them to do HIV testing trying
to encourage others to be safe
disseminating messages and organizing
events for other people in their
community and in terms of consequences
there was a fair bit that we could see
in terms of potential links to other
kinds of information interaction I think
probably the thing that's the most
interesting to me was this idea of
information use that people felt like
once they were trying to educate others
about HIV
that that made them feel like they
needed to align their own behavior with
what they were suggesting for others so
from my point of view this is an
interesting potential area to look at in
terms of ways of promoting behavior
changes to promote helping others so in
summary here I have shown that community
involvement affects how much people get
information about HIV and also how much
they use it and it appears to have a
relationship with how much they share it
and I've identified three theoretical
mediators that potentially could be
areas for community level intervention
there are social costs of information
seeking network expertise accessibility
and community relevance so next I'm
going to talk about what makes
environments information rich and talk
about this as a way of intervening in
the informatics area so I've introduced
three categories here that are drawn
from fieldwork in dialysis clinics so
this was the e kidney project and here
we were asking the question about
basically what are the characteristics
of this information world but one of the
things that we really found out was that
people saw the dialysis clinic as a very
information rich environment it was a
place where they could find out anything
they might want to know and in some ways
I barely even needed to ask for anything
because it was already there so here we
were trying to then look at well what is
it that's making this environment be
that for people why is why are people
finding it to be information rich for
them and how is that something that we
might be able to understand in order to
leverage so this was based on
ethnographic observation in three
dialysis clinics in Michigan we were in
a rural clinic a suburban clinic and an
urban clinic and we also did enter
in-depth interviews with people at each
clinic we've sampled them based on how
they were behaving in the clinic so just
to give you an idea yes probably many of
you know what dialysis is like but
people typically are sitting in chairs
they're separated by a mechanical kidney
that's what the kidney looks like and
that is blood going through the tubes
there and so people really they come and
they sit in a really big room and
there's a whole bunch of patients who
are all together simultaneously so as
you probably can imagine people find
dialysis to be an extremely challenging
experience very uncomfortable physically
very constraining in terms of the
schedule because they need to go there
three times a week for four hours at a
time and for those of you familiar with
information science literature I was
initially looking at this through the
framework of alfreda Chapman's life in
the round theory but found that it
wasn't sufficient to really explain
everything that we were seeing and so
that's where these categories came from
so first is this idea of ambience so
information environments can this is my
contention is an information
environments are become rich when there
is information around that people can
engage with in a variety of different
ways depending on their particular needs
and so one of the ways is through
routinization so having treatment
routines that involve provision of
information and address it on a cyclical
basis opportunities to ask questions etc
but also there was a kind of social
component so for those of you who are
familiar with Erving Goffman's work in
sociology there were certain kinds of
interaction rituals that we saw between
people over time things like daily
greetings waiting rooms small talk and
these became kind of wrote types of rows
on reserve interaction by which people
learned about the disease through the
experience of others also there was a
fair bit as i mentioned people are
coming together they're all being
treated together that's pretty unusual
and so there was quite a bit of learning
through informal observation and through
imitation of various kinds so things
like learning from the how did how to
tolerate dialysis for four hours so what
other people do how do i how could I
learn from that the use of humor was
important thing that was role modeled as
a way to make things tolerable also
there is a lot of trial and error so
people are having a repeated experience
that they're learning from and here for
example this is somebody learning how to
prevent cramping through the process of
dialysis so the next so that's ambience
so you have a number of things about the
environment in the way things function
that in the availability of
knowledgeable people who have similar
experiences and you can engage with it
in a range of ways then this concept is
alignment and this is really about
people who have shared experiences or
challenges coming together and this is a
concept that is presented a lot of the
peer based interactions that we see in
the health arena but the kind of shared
challenge that people really were
focused on in this environment was how
they were going to make dialysis
tolerable and so they produce a kind of
local information that met their needs
that they shared with one another that
really focused on that question of how
are we going to find a way to go on and
make this tolerable so there's a kind of
concept i'm introducing now which is
experiential information which was at
the core of this alignment idea and so
for those of you who've done any kind of
work with patient peer based
organizations you might have sort of
come across the work that shows that
pure based interaction is extremely
helpful for patients and some of the
reasons why I would contend based on
this and other studies I've done is
because of the availability of
experiential information and
experiential information includes
practical strategies which often are not
things that are instructed in a
healthcare setting so things like how
are you going to be comfortable while
you're on dialysis things like hand
warmers pillows when to take your
medication so your blood pressure as a
crash things like that and also people
really talk to each other about
different clinics they learned about
which ones were good where were the
staff people I could actually trust or
who we're going to
be properly because that's actually
something that people find very painful
and it's quite variable in terms of
skill and there was also a kind of tales
that started to circulate amongst
patients around things like there was
people talked about a clinic that
supposedly was one where you could get
dialysis in a chair that would massage
you and nobody had ever actually been to
a clinic where you could have the
massaging chair but everybody talked
about it and really wanted it to be true
so that you sort of see the sort of
production of tales that become shared
also people talked about how to learn to
adhere to the kinds of guidelines around
food to take restrictions around fluid
intake and things like that and so
there's a real art that's involved in a
lot of work around figuring out how
that's going to work in daily life and
that's something that people learn from
each other and the sort of personal
story is also an important part of
experiential information and here we see
for those of you familiar with social
comparison literature both upward
comparisons of people finding the
stories that people who are doing better
than them inspiring so things like the
people who got transplants they became
an inspiration but then there was also
the downward comparison which it became
like a cautionary tale around who I'm
going to what who I don't want to be
like so patients who died patients who
weren't doing well and trying to infer
from what what they were doing what to
not do oneself so this particular
experiential information included those
practical strategies as well as personal
stories and those were things that
people found very helpful but I want to
also introduce this think this concept
of aggregation and this is a way for
people to share what they're learning
about the experience of dialysis and
what I saw here was a kind of incomplete
aggregation across these clinics so
people talk to each other about things
but it was mostly one-on-one it was
highly variable based on the SAP there's
a lot of sound
clinic dialyzers are really loud and
people need to keep distance between
them because of things like blood
splatters and things like that and and
so as a result they aren't necessarily
it's not necessarily easy to talk to
patients and a lot of people really long
for more opportunities to talk to other
people and so here I'm also suggesting
aggregation is something that could
potentially be improved in dialysis
clinic environments and I've been
working with colleagues on online peer
mentoring I've done some work around
kidney disease young young adults with
kidney disease and now working with some
projects related to dialysis clinic
based peer mentoring using technology as
well as face-to-face components so here
I hope I persuaded you that there were
three and three themes or three aspects
of this environment that made clinics
information rich I'm suggesting that
these are more portable concepts that
could be used from the point of view of
designing environments to make them
information rich for patients the idea
of ambience alignment and aggregation
the next claim i'm making focuses on
collective patterns so a lot of the work
that's out there that looks at
technology use and information
acquisition is very individualistic and
i've done a lot of studies now that have
looked at the actual patterns of
behaviors around exchanging information
sharing it and using it that are much
more collaborative and collective than
has typically been identified and so
here i'm going to talk about one
specific kind of collective pattern and
this is based on the hope project and
this is a CDC funded project that's
focused on HIV and STI prevention
amongst african-american young adults in
Michigan and it's a network based
intervention that involves face-to-face
components and we were also adding
technology to try to amplify so we did a
series of focus groups in which we were
talking to young people about what they
would like to see in an intervention and
this was a very interesting study for me
because it certainly reinforced the
value of quality
of work where you don't necessarily know
what you're going to hear because what
happened here was the young people
talked about something completely
different and they did so consistently
and in relation to everything that we
raised and that was the issue of trust
so the issue of trust being the central
concern that these young people talked
about led us to the looking at the
literature in sociology of trust and so
for those of you who might be familiar
with it basically this the work in
sociology sociology of trust shows that
we have certain kinds of expectations
regarding the conduct of other people
and they're rooted in culture and they
tend to be systematic also we have trust
in a range of targets ranging from
technologies to people to information
and also that social contexts reinforce
trustworthy behavior so insofar as we
know that we're going to see somebody
again we're more likely to behave in a
trustworthy fashion or if we know people
in common we're more likely to behave in
a trustworthy fashion because there's a
retribution associated with how we act
so this particular theoretical framework
is one that I used then to look at data
from this research that was done with
young people in a Midwestern state and
it's a state state that has a
disproportionate rate of HIV and STI s
and actually this is one of the regions
in the u.s. that is unusual because it's
recently had an active syphilis epidemic
which is not very common and is an area
that's predominantly african-american so
we did focus groups with young people
and one of the groups focused on LGBT
youth and they were typically 90 minutes
to two hours and about a people per
group so to give you an idea of who was
in these focus groups they were an
average age of 18
they were 71 percent female and all
african-american and there was a mostly
heterosexual with an lgb minority and as
you could guess from their age they were
not typically on high school so that was
a that's not surprising and they were
typically not in the workforce so in
looking at the kinds of issues they
raised so first we can we talk them
about their reactions to the issue of
HIV in their community and sti's and
young people really harnessed a kind of
explanation as to what they saw as
driving the epidemic and it really
focused on a kind of indictment of
morality and so sociological trust
Theory talks about oxy illogical
distrust and that concerns our trust in
the morality of other people and the
most common complaint that people had
was that other that other people in this
community they don't care about
themselves they don't care about others
and they're just they just do things
because they don't care and this is
something that was a really common theme
that came up through many many comments
across all the groups and this
particular kind of indictment around
moral trust is something I'm going to
pick up later in the context of design
implications people also talked about
their social context as being very much
supporting lack of trust so they talked
about things like families that were not
not well that didn't have good
enforcement of we're monitoring of
children they talked about a social
environment where there was a real
disinvestment and people didn't care
everybody was trying to leave this area
because there were no jobs people were
depressed and they felt that this was
something that was underlying they just
the distrust distrust that they had for
other people and there was also when
they talked about different kinds of
information sources they talked about
different institution
and one of the things that is not
probably not surprising if you've had
any experience working with
african-americans is that there was a
real distrust of the CDC and government
and its lack of action and response to
the needs of african-americans there's
really good reasons you probably all
know about the Tuskegee experiments and
things like that which were actually run
by the forerunner of the CDC and you
know these are things that people know
about and they they were very concerned
about also in addition to the government
there were concerns about doctors people
really felt like doctors were just in it
for the money they didn't really care
about them they felt that teachers were
very judgmental and also very gossipy
and talked to it didn't keep people's
confidences they found their churches to
be often very helpful for many things
but there were some people that they
found very judgmental there as well so
that wasn't necessarily a good place to
learn about sexuality and so really what
came out best from their perspective
where community-based organizations who
like Planned Parenthood or other kinds
of organizations that they saw as honest
and upfront with them there was also a
real distrust in using social
technologies to connect with other
people and so over and above what we
might think about around privacy
concerns about looking for HIV or STI
information online there were also
people's concern had concerns about
things like privacy breaches one of the
things that I was talking to Patti about
yesterday but that I didn't expect is
actually that people may not have
control over their cell phones so people
talked a lot about other people stealing
their phone or other people having their
phone and so they were very afraid about
getting texts from about sexual health
on their phones they were also they
really saw the Internet as a place where
there was just a lot of gossip that was
very negative a lot of it around
sexuality and HIV STI related rumors and
people did a lot of fighting online
around allegations of infidelity and
things like that
so people were not very comfortable with
the idea of doing a lot of interacting
with other people online related to
sexuality they in this would this was up
that I found disturbing there was also
in addition to not trusting information
technologies and as a way to interact
with others there were concerns around
prevention technologies and so one of
the things that so many of you might
know that there was a kind of sexual
health education that was really
promoted in the Bush era that many of
these young people grew up with which
was the abstinence only until marriage
programs and these young people were
receiving sex education frequently that
actually was really emphasizing the
failures of condoms rather than their
successes and they were actually like
think they were learning as in this
quote here that it was actually they
wouldn't work so they didn't necessarily
trust condoms they also in this around
HIV test I would say was a lot of
confusion around the idea of a window
period how long is a test accurate will
people how will people go out and become
infected immediately after their test
how long are the results real that kind
of thing so people there was some people
did trust in these things but there was
a current of distrust around these
technologies to and then with regards to
information there is a real kind of
concern about official information
through public health channels etc about
how HIV is transmitted and so as you can
see this is a quote from somebody who's
not believing that touching hands will
not transmit HIV and the sociology of
rumor tells us that in situations where
official information is not trusted
that's when rumors go rampant and this
is something that we saw here in this
community where people were talking
about some people who are supposedly
spreading the disease deliberately
people were concerned about trying to
identify the apart
building where people had it st is there
was a lot of kind of trying to protect
yourself through the idea of avoiding
certain people which makes a lot of
sense when you think about the fact that
they are trusting in the technologies
that could potentially help them like
condoms so what do you do then well I
guess you avoid somebody you think is
going to be a threat team so I'm hoping
that based on this I have shown you that
trust is something that can be systemic
and collective in nature that it's
really important when we're thinking
about designing interventions of certain
types this is an HIV example but we I
think we need to think seriously about
trust as a system of collective meaning
that affects the success of what we do
with regards to informatics applications
and also to think about the carryover of
trust between different levels as
sociological trust theory talks about
and that's in that system of meaning it
suggests that our institutional origins
as intervention providers would be very
important to the trust of potential
users and I've also argued here that
trusting is a collective pattern and
that further underlines my case that for
community health informatics the last
point I wanted to make was that we often
think about our interventions as serving
a patient but as many of you know
already that a lot of the care that
people get is happening outside of
healthcare settings and in fact people
spend the majority of their lives
outside of healthcare and we kind of
make an assumption or at least ice I
know I did and many of my colleagues did
that there are going to be supportive
interactions with families caregivers
come along to appointments they're going
to be helpful it's all going to you know
we can sort of assume that it's going to
be there and it's going to be supportive
we can almost black box at it we don't
need to think about it but my work has
suggested that health information
interactions in community
families can be related to or associated
with very contentious and antagonistic
interactions and so here I'm talking
about work from the families illness and
information project and you're looking
at family networks and the question is
to look at the kinds of information
activities families are engaging in the
methods were to sample families so I'm
following families 32 families I sampled
patients if any of you are from the VA
you might be interested to know that a
number of our patients were recruited
from the VA so we sample patients and
then they brought their family members
in to the study and they're defining
what their family is so we didn't set
that up for them and we're following
them over a two-year period so there's
five contacts with these people over a
two-year period we've been doing
individual interviews with them as well
as a modification of focus groups called
family group interviewing as well as
doing surveys and network data gathering
out over time and one step also involves
home tours which looks at how people are
managing health information in
collaboration at hope these are the
methods that we are using for analysis
so there were 32 families and their half
people with diabetes in their families
and half people with HIV in their
families and a little more than half
were wider european american but a good
chunk or african american as well and as
you can see the population a little bit
younger amongst people with HIV versus
those with diabetes and that reflects
the demographics of the disease as well
the gender balance was reversed so more
men in the HIV pop group and more women
in the diabetes group and about a
quarter of our folks were had high
school education or less most of them
were low income and that was one of the
things that we wanted to look at so the
first thing I want to say is there
definitely was support in some families
and in terms of social support theory
there were good evidence of things like
informational support and some of the
kinds of interactions that were involved
in that included things like forwarding
emails about new science to try to get
somebody else to feel hopeful about
their disease helping people achieve
their goals and things like that so
there what that did exist but there are
also negative family responses to
illness this is some of the responses
around HIV there were more negative
responses there than in the diabetes
group as you might expect but people
were not necessarily helpful or willing
to talk about the disease in the HIV
group but more generally I wanted to
make a point about the negative
information sharing experiences that
people talked about and a lot of this
came up around attempted influence
especially in the diabetes groups so as
you can see this is a quote from
somebody who's talking about the idea of
too much caring from somebody who's
trying to get them to follow dietary
requirements and this is works as and
informing because people are trying to
use biomedical information repeatedly to
make their points and people often felt
really criticized or infantilized by
these kinds of interactions as you can
see and they sort of rather immature
response from somebody they're deciding
to eat two Donuts instead of one because
of getting feedback from their wife
another thing that happened in several
families was the idea of unwanted
interference especially with doctors so
family members who go to health care
appointments and then they are agenda
setting and the talking about things
that the patient doesn't want to do and
here are somebody talking about it being
really interfering by the family member
so that's there's a lot more to say
about that I'm working on a paper now
that's focused on health-related social
control and role of information and
technology in that but I wanted to give
you a sort of taste of those findings so
that I can make the point that
information sharing is not necessarily
going to be supportive or helpful and in
the information science field we
actually have a history of identifying
in defining information as help so it's
actually one in the same but I'm trying
to emphasize here that it may not be
helpful depending on the specific
relational context so in conclusion this
was a call to community health
informatics and I'm going to talk about
how these findings show that so I've
shown that there are differing
information environments and they affect
access to information a big part of this
focuses on adoption of technologies what
kinds of resources are being used in
different communities and how they
affect that it affect access to
information and I showed with the young
MSM that there is in this community and
there's other studies I could show you
of mine that show that there's
variability in that access so it's a
socially embedded process and we need to
think about information environments and
communities we're thinking about
consumers also I talked about in the
dialysis contacts three aspects of
information environments that made them
information rich I talked about ambience
alignment and aggregation and those I
suggest are important ways that we can
think about influencing the setting in
order to affect people's access to
information and that's an aspect of
communities I talked about trust in the
context of young african-americans as a
collective pattern and that sits
alongside other work of mine that shows
that information interaction and
technology use often involve collective
patterns of collaboration or interaction
various kinds and those are not
necessarily things that we think about
when we are designing and implementing
technologies and also when talking about
the families I showed that health
information interaction can be
contentious and antagonistic and that
because of that we need to be concerned
about when we are deploying something is
always to play deployed in a group
context whether we're thinking about it
that way or not and it's quite possible
to have unintended consequences or
things happening that we don't
necessarily anticipate if we're not
keeping that in our frameworks so the
community health informatics approach
that i'm talking about that builds on
these findings includes a focus on
marginalized groups experience health
disparities also it's I'm arguing for
intervention at a family or community
level and that involves trying to look
at mediators at a community level and
community you're family level outcomes
so we might be looking at things like
the functioning of families or
functioning of communities when we're
thinking about how we're intervening
also we need to think about those
unintended consequences and that's only
possible we start to think about a group
level intervention also I've talked
about building information rich
environments as a potential strategy for
trying to create settings that people
can use to gain the information and
support they need also when I was
talking about the young men identified
three community level mediators that can
potentially be an area for influence in
informatics interventions social costs
Network expertise and community
relevance and I talked about trust and
in a paper that's forthcoming in jamia
which talks about the African American
youth I've I'd have introduced a concept
called trust centered design and I can
talk about this in more depth but this
is intended to be a systematic process
that operation Eliza's the idea that at
the center to build trust in an
intervention we need to systematically
be thinking at about trust as I'm
to level phenomenon looking at
individuals groups technologies and
institutions and that it maps on to our
intervention strategy including user
needs and intervention objectives to
functional specifications and
interaction design there are specific
recommendations in this that are really
about my specific context of HIV
interventions a young monks young
african-american so the specifics might
change depending on a user group or
disease context but this general
approach is one that I'm advocating as a
way of working with marginalized groups
especially young african-americans and
specifically in the context have my of
HIV I've been looking at the
implications of that trust center design
for certain recommendations like having
your intervention connect to an offline
world and connecting to institutions
that are more likely to be trusted like
community based organizations looking at
the issue so if you recall the work
their concerns about morality of others
trying to use technology as a way to
allow young people who are motivated to
aggregate their experiences with regards
to using condoms or other HIV and STI
prevention work and through that to be
able to communicate norms so to allow
them to more explicitly communicate
norms and also for people who wish to to
use technology to try to promote a kind
of group accountability so people who
want to make certain commitments to
others or couples that want to talk
about their arrangements with others
they can do so on a particular online
intervention and also thinking about
technology as a tool for collective
action for people who are motivated to
act around health issues okay so in
terms of future work I just wanted to
highlight a few areas i'm continuing to
work in one is trying to
map the connection between information
use and exposure to health behaviors and
I have a paper for coming about that in
j syst also looking at trying to build
continue to build that theoretical basis
for community and family level entry
informatics interventions and also I'm
increasingly moving into a more
interventional style of research we're
trying to instantiate some of these
insights in actual interventions and
evaluating and there's several ongoing
projects that are doing this okay so
just to conclude now I told you how I
came to this work and made the case that
this is an underlying substantial
problem that we have in the informatics
and information services fields related
to reaching marginalized communities I
talked to you about my general research
program which focuses on that question
of what health information technologies
and services would look like if
marginalized groups and their needs and
experiences were at the center of design
and implementation and I've shown you
through a series of finding some of the
things that we miss out on if we don't
think about community and family level
issues especially in disparity
populations and I've started to answer
that question about what systems
technologies and services would look
like by looking at the concept of
community and family level interventions
theoretical mediators cross centered
design and design of information rich
environments and I talk to you about
where my work is going and I hope that I
have persuasively made the case to you
that community health informatics is an
important approach to be thinking about
especially when working with
marginalized communities and i hope you
will hear this call and be motivated in
your own work to follow that in make
calls of your own thanks very much
and I open to questions questions for
Doug reveal John so thank you that was
really fascinating I was intrigued by
your mention of the family group
interviews that sounded like something
between focus groups and individual
interviews you tell us more about them
sure so it is an adaptation of a focus
group methodology so focus groups
typically work on the assumption that
people don't necessarily know each other
beforehand so here we make the
assumption that they do and they're
being asked to comment on their group
interactions so the kinds of questions
they answer are things about their
experience as a family and it gets them
to reflect on their group their group
interactions and also one of the nice
things about it is it actually lets us
see the interactions between people
because sooner or later they kind of
forget we're there then we get to
actually see the things we hear about an
individual interviews and so it can be
very informative about what those family
interactions are like so you get to know
people really well when you're following
them for two years and see them five
times and know all their family members
too so so that's generally the method i
also used a whole family methodology
which is adopted from nursing which
which involves individual interviews
with all the members of a family to talk
about the family group and so i've used
that at the beginning and end and the
family group interviews in the middle I
find that people do say different things
when they're in groups individually so
so that's the method and they're
recorded and things like that I have a
question yes so I'm really impressed
with the case you have made for the
importance of trust it's almost
necessary prerequisite to intervene in
information interventions having an
impact is that kind of yes so so given
that trust is so deeply embedded in sort
of has so much history in time to it I
mean the Tuskegee Institute is just one
thing there's the whole Henrietta Lacks
story and all that kind of stuff so so
can we use our technologies to
develop improve inculcate trust or are
or are we just kind of at at the mercy
of whatever trust relationships exist
and then the tools get used in whatever
ways you saw some ways that tools are
actually used in harmful yeah ways so
can we improve trust with our
information technology or do we just
have to use it in places where trust
exists it's a great question so one
thing I will say is that I do really
believe in community engagement
strategies as a way of doing this work
so of course that means you need to be
very careful about who you're working
with and you need to be working with
groups that are being trust their
already trusted but with regards to
using technologies to build trust that's
one of the things that I was hoping to
come so this is work that's ongoing but
I'm hoping through our work that we can
try to demonstrate that do that we can
kind of build trust in a community by
offering opportunities for things like
online commitments offering people
ability to communicate norms and things
like that that's more dealing with trust
within the community but you're in so
you're also talking about trust in our
technologies have I answered your
question right yeah I guess I guess what
I'm getting at is this whole idea of do
I make sure when I use the technology or
create the intervention that trust
exists all right working with trusted
sources yeah or is there a way for me to
use that technology to improve the trust
so that where trust didn't exist it
starts to yeah and I guess I have to
you're talking about trust in you as an
intern as a provider I guess I'm saying
the trust that needs to exist in the
ambience we're in the environment yeah
the trust that needs to exist in that
setting in order for the information
intervention to be successful if I'm
passing this information about sexually
transmitted diseases and folks don't
trust the technology or the source or
the message then they're not going to
follow it so do i need to find places
where trust exists or use other
mechanisms to get trust to exist work in
technology help us with trust yeah as
opposed to heaven yeah and I would say
I think it can but i think it probably
would need to be part of an iterative
process so for example if you use
technologies in a participatory fashion
then people are more light or designing
them in a participatory faction and i
think some of those insights from HCI
are really valuable here because if
people are contributing to their design
they feel more ownership in it and
they're more likely to trust it because
it reflects what they wanted to so i
think that you can work the way you
deploy technologies and the kind of
social intervention surrounding it is
one way that our technologies could help
us because it's kind of the impetus for
new kinds of interactions as far as
interactions with providers sorry so if
if they listened to me about the design
and maybe they're trustworthy and I and
I should listen to them about something
else as opposed to the design just sort
of came out of the blue yeah yeah and I
think that I mean another thing around
trust is I've learned it takes a lot of
time and I mean I have one of the
projects I was that I just flashed up
here which is enhancing the community
health information infrastructure that's
in inkster northwest detroit and flint
which are all urban african-american
heavily just hi hi just diabetes rates
communities in michigan and here i've
been working with them for two years on
trying to figure what we're going to do
and so sometimes are unfortunately our
grant mechanisms sometimes are not all
that helpful I mean allowing us to it's
often we need to move really fast but
cross does take time and also community
presence i think is an important aspect
of trust so if you're there for the
rough times as well as the good times in
the community that can go a long way to
building trust so are you going there to
help them with their fundraising events
or you know just sometimes somebody come
over for dinner once in a while like
things like that where you're actually
getting to know people and you're I mean
one thing that I end up doing which I
didn't expect but it makes perfect sense
as I actually do a fair bit of men
Turing with people in these communities
who want to pursue academic careers so I
end up being the you know the person
they know in the Academy who they can
call and they feel comfortable and i
become the person who kind of acts as a
bridge for them so I guess what I'm
saying is there's like there are a lot
of different things that go that we can
do as intervenors and some of it's not
easy and I think we need funding
mechanisms to help us build partnerships
to help us fund nonprofits to actually
work with us because often our funding
mechanisms don't allow for that the N
uni ecommerce they use consumer ratings
as a basis for trust ascendant me try
doing that with health information um so
that's one thing that I'm suggesting
here is doing people are very
interesting the idea things like rating
of condoms rating of sexual health
related behaviors and things like that
so that's something that I think there's
room for and that's a new application
I've been suggesting with regards to
rating health information per se I
haven't really seen that application at
this point but I mean in a sense it's
somewhat embedded in things like Amazon
where your rating books and stuff like
that but yeah okay well thanks dr. vino
for a thank you present a shin thank you
and I have cards if anybody wants them